Now we can say what the order of a solver is.
A solver is a method such as the forward Euler method
that we used to solve differential equations on the computer going step by step.
For the forward Euler method, we know that the global truncation error, the error after a finite time
is something like a constant times the step size.
In the general case, it may not be the step size but this step size raise to a certain power,
and that power is called the order.
The forward Euler method has an order of one, so that we end up with the constant times h.
More powerful methods we have larger orders, say two or four,
and again, we have to keep in mind that this constant depends on time.
It may grow exponentially with time for instance.
This constant does not depends on step size, however. Know this site.
Be sure not to confuse this notion of order with the notion of order of a differential equation.
When we have differential equation of this sort for instance, this is of order two.
The order of a differential equation is a different story.